Today's topic. Um, how do.
I start this? What's this? What, what, why, why the hesitation.
Twin sisters <laugh>
Okay. Thank you. And before anybody gets upset, be like, oh,
you guys really wanted us to give them like a courtesy.
That's the least we could have done before we do a video, uh, S shining on them.
So I message Walter and I let 'em know. I'm like, Hey, man,
I just wanted to give you a courtesy heads up that we're gonna cover you simply
for a sugar baby. So I did let him know before we did a video on him. <laugh>
oh my see, we learn regrow. We get better.
So I'm gonna say this before this whole sing cards. <laugh>
too much. I personally do not care who anybody dates me.
It's just like the need to lie to your fans.
The need to be a hypocrite about your own ideals.
And so I'm gonna just play the video and you guys can see what I,
I'm gonna just give you guys a quick summary.
So you guys understand where we're at. All right. Fresh prince CEO. All right.
The big fraud. He himself claims that he's fall in love with the woman,
or he's really gotten into her. And that she's into him for him.
DJ academics came on. The podcast said, Hey, bro,
that girl's not into you for you.
You said something on like last show. When I was on,
that was a little bit alarming.
I have to be careful what they want me for that being said, this shorty here,
bro. Listen, listen, listen that shorty there, bro.
Walk me from me a hundred percent. See what you want.
You said that she was very different from every girl you meet in Miami.
When I've heard you speak about every girl in Miami before you generalize. No,
that being said, when I met her, I saw she had maintain it yet.
She had to be like in certain circles where like, you know what,
she's gone through streets. If.
He says that being said one more time. If he says that being said one.
More time. I think I get what you're saying. I get what you're saying.
I think I'm gonna have to say, but, but you know, that being said,
let's just let the live video put, okay.
What does it mean? That she's different than not thinking like a Miami girl?
I just pointed you out someone I'm like,
explain that because I've heard you say so for example, right?
<Laugh> this girl is, this girl is yes.
Please explain. Yes. Explain. Go ahead.
Yes. You go. Mm-hmm have you watched interview one? The,
these parts of seeing all the Miami women being shadow on while Walter's there.
Like the white girl beside me is very different. That being.
Said, she's not into like designer going crazy. Like, oh, I need to have this.
And that. It's more like she wants a good time with me.
Okay. I don't know why I just got this random link. Miami, Florida.
Let's look through. Wait, wait a second.
Wait a second. 22. Still in college.
Why do you think she she's interested in? You ask her? I was gonna say,
can I answer this last course? <laugh> um, I feel like.
The first March day that I met you having that genuine conversation on the boat,
like.
On a yeah. Oh, on the boat <laugh> was it 60 foot long? Was it 85 foot?
I.
Couldn't even tell you. Uh, see, I am a very big personality person.
So if he came up to me and he just came and was like, Hey,
let me get your number. That's a note from me.
The fact that he invited me and he's been, he invited me out before. Yeah.
And it was just the fact that me and my roommate were sitting at home. He yacht,
no, me and my roommate were sitting at home and I was like, wow,
what are we gonna do tonight? And then like, at that moment he texted me.
He was like, Hey.
Go ride with scooters or get on the yacht, talk about it.
And he's right. I'm not a materialistic person at all.
I could be if I wanted to. I don't care about that.
Like my dream car is a Honda civic. Like I don't, there's nothing about me.
Materialistic.
Hold. No. Who said he invited you before? Why you didn't go before? Hold on,
hold, hold on. I was always.
Busy or like I was pretty hold.
I was living on wait minute. No, you see problem. Miss.
You think that because have clout everyone walking for clout,
however for you that's that's true for me. It's not. I actually have game, bro.
Right? That being said, hold on. That being said, right, bro. Not game.
Your experience right with girls is tainted. Cuz you wanna see it for clout. Oh,
that's who bro. For me.
Horrors in this house. There's some whores in this tatted.
There's some wars in this house. There's some whores in this house.
I said certified freak.
There's some seven days a week's we as P make that pullout game week.
Yeah. In this house. Yeah. Yeah.
You E with some wet PS.
Bring a, can you explain what was on the screen? Her getting cash act.
That's being said. I wanna get to know the real.
You don't wanna get to know you from.
Can I, so,
so you're so you're essentially basically proven what they say is wrong in terms
of you don't give a about a high value band. Right? I.
Don't thats like that's you don't.
No. So.
So it's funny. I care that he has a personality and I can be around him.
Don't you? He's.
He's a high value man.
No, I really don't. I did not care about his chain.
I did not care about his watch. I don't care that. Beat it up. N.
Word, catch a charge, extra large and extra hard.
Put this P word right in your face. Swipe your nose. Like a credit.
Card. I saw shoot that had maintained yet.
She hadn't been like in certain circles where like, you know what?
she's gone through the streets, dude. She doesn't want club, bro. Honestly,
she didn't wanna do this live stream. She's doing this for me.
So I appreciate her for that.
<laugh> did I know you? I D know.
You. I do a Hale. Well it's inside.
I actually have him bro. Right game.
This is your alpha male dating coach. <laugh>
<laugh> did I know you? I, I know you. I.
Do a kale. Well it's inside spit in my mouth book in my eyes.
This P word is wet. Come take a dive. <laugh>.
Be.
<Laugh>. And personally, like I said,
back in let's just watch, never forget this man has a thousand body counts.
Okay. This man slept with a thousand plus women. Oh my God.
Like beginning to end. So how we met the honest truth.
With we met on seeking.
Yeah. So we, we met on there. We definitely, uh,
spoke and then got Instagram. And that was it for like a couple months. Yeah.
And we didn't talk for like a, for like a.
Minute. We didn't talk for like months, cuz I didn't really wanna meet people.
Um, for a while I was kind of taking a break cuz I had a interesting like living
situation at the time. Mm-hmm <affirmative> so I was not meeting people.
We're talking about.
The savagery of women nowadays. Yeah.
Last week you were with this dude this week. You're with this dude.
I see everything. <laugh> I'm not gonna say no name,
but I will say she's here. Oh and she's beside fresh.
What the? Oh, better to girl.
<Laugh> oh dear. She wasn't. She wasn't. She wasn't ready to date.
She wasn't ready to, she wasn't ready to date. Let's just keep.
You got something to myself. Miranda.
Wait, wait. I feel like you are trying to expose me,
but like it's you have to like date around. Hold on. You gotta come back.
Let's normalize. Playing the bachelorette in your personal life.
Hold you wanna have a hot girl summer. All right.
You gonna have a bunch of hot girls summers. Bye yourself. Pause, pause, pause.
Don't all I'm gonna say no, my turn. That's all I'm gonna say. Okay.
Next it's embarrassing for a man to marry Ahoe and try to turn her into a
housewife. You know, what's the scary part, man. Ity.
If you ask your wife for one of these girls, bro, you take her seriously.
She can't have a pair bond. So what happens is you wipe her up,
you take her in and she's hella, hella mus on her body.
You know what I'm saying? And at that point, what do you get?
Are you beat a product? It can't even work properly. I didn't say nothing.
It's Myron. It's not me. It's Myron. Who's calling him out.
Let's go. She, she wanna be a bachelorette. Literally her best life. Hold on.
Let's normalize. Playing the bachelorette in your personal life.
We do what guys do and then we get so much for it, but y'all do it.
And then you're like, yo bro, that's Savage as.
Like you can't even be a decent woman and not be a.
outta here, bro. No, you dumb. I'm not insecure. I'm very secure.
And my confidence. I don't wanna wife up. No ho. Right?
And I'm tired of women out here telling dudes smoke. Dick energy, Dick energy.
You're insecure. You're insecure. You're insecure.
I'm not gonna the Lamborghini dealership with 300 bands for a Lambo with 200,000
miles on it, bro. It's. I need you guys to hold these women accountable too.
They gotta meet your metric. We don't want hose. Okay.
You wanna be a ho. That's fine. But you gotta lay in your bed and sleep there.
Most guys in reality are not going to accept you for being Ahoe and
put a ring on it. It's always gonna bother them. Okay?
Don't don't all I'm gonna say no, my turn. I.
Don't even sit to this thing. This is their idea. These are,
these are ideologies by their definition. She is what she is, right? They,
they consider Ahoe that's the red pill movement. That's them. I'm not mad at it.
But Nick Myron is.
It's.
Use sugar sites, right.
To hit up girls and we don't pay it same and
go with them. We get it for free. So that being said,
she told me, Hey, I was on seeking. And I said, bet,
I go on there anyway. Salt, the chicks we met.
On seeking. Yeah. So we, we met on there. We definitely, um, spoke.
And then our Instagram.
She told you, Shane tell you on a yacht.
We went on multiple days after the yacht. She's like, yo,
I gotta be honest with you. Right?
Cause I don't wanna mess up anything in the most. You mean bro,
on something bro, tell you. I shortly told me bro, like the fact she told me,
I was like, but you know what? I respect that. If you.
If, if I know guys are paying you for to,
to smash mm-hmm <affirmative> that right there is a, is a red flag for me.
But what the is she doing on there?
Okay. So hundred percent bro. I don't know what she doing on there.
I being said, Hey, she might need some money.
I don't know what's going on there.
Bro. It was it a, a red flag.
When you found out she's on seeking arrangements and she decided
to come link with you only when you were on the yacht.
No, a hundred percent. No bro. In Miami,
almost every though you see that that's good looking bro is on sugar site. I.
Thought she was different than all the other girls. No yet,
but now she's doing whatever they Miami girls doing.
Okay. Be honest. So my honest got you body count bro. No cap ready for it.
It's over a thousand
that as serious. I remember I told you, right? I told you about Barbados. When,
so basically guys, I'm gonna break a for you. Right? So doing live right now.
So in Barbados, right?
I can tell you before there's a whole culture of women coming from UK,
coming from like, you know, uh, Italy.
Because the way you talk about women, especially because you're in Miami.
Mm-hmm <affirmative> you just prove that saying that if she's here and she's
new, those rule don't apply. You don't talk to just a Miami audience.
You talk to an audience that's literally all around the world.
So you're pretty much telling your audience everything I tell you doesn't apply
to Y because you're not in Miami. I thought you were giving universal rules.
That's hold on, hold. Hold on. Hold on. We're talking about her. I got you. No,
no. I know. I know, but I I'm.
I'm talking about how you are saying she doesn't apply to many things that you
would say about the.
Normal because now everybody that follows them are from.
Miami. That's my point. This advice doesn't apply to everybody. Yeah. Right?
Because they live in that place where you've been in Miami. It's a weird spot.
It's gonna warp your view of ladies, right? Oh yeah.
They're all on sugar babies. Like they're all just suddenly bro.
That's that's what happens where you live specifically?
As far as the whole incident personally, me personally,
I don't think it's that big of a deal. I don't think it's that important.
I do think it's more evidence of what we already know about fresh,
which is one he's a liar. Okay. He needs, he's a fraudulent person, right?
Claims to have this body count, to sell his courses,
claims to have met her and then went on dates,
then found out she's on the sugar baby site.
Then when it comes out that she's on seeking arrangements,
they actually livestream. Where's like, no, we met on seeking.
Like everything is smoking mirrors. Right.
Which is fine at the end of the day.
If you want to sell an image and you gotta lie to do it, do it. Okay.
But as far as, um, you, yeah, you, you you're definitely simp. Yeah.
I mean you guys know. And I think we all know this.
If these two guys were hearing this story from any other man about him being
involved with that woman, what would they call the you.
Straight up, straight up.
Blue pill, beta,
all the other lay mass terms that they got once it's one of them straight up.
It fun. You shouldn't date a girl like that. But you know she did.
And that's what you see a lot of from red pill coaches,
they're gonna sell you on all these false ideas, right? They'll say never get,
never get married. Half of them are married. Half of them are married.
They'll tell you marriage. This is trap marriage, a trap. They get married.
One of them even had the audacity say like, I don't know. I just,
we just eloped. It just happened. What? That's just, you,
you spent years screaming about marriage and how terrible it is and that you
would never do it. Are you just happen to get married? Mm-hmm <affirmative>.
What then you gonna go around on call ladies silly and stupid when they dance on
single ladies by Beyonce when she's married to Jay-Z.
But look at you doing the same thing. That's it.
Man. It's all smoking mirrors. But even the fans know that. Listen, listen,
there's one thing I can say about the first fan base is that they all know that.
Cause whenever you said.
Yeah, yeah. The comments like we know you don't get any. So I'm,
I'm gonna say they're not stupid.
I think they're really there for the entertainment.
Well I'm like, why do you need to lie to them? Yeah. She rough.
You ask her on multiple dates. She never shows up. Then you're like, yo,
come on a yacht. And she shows up. Yay. She's not.
Materialistic. She's not, not, it's not for Jean car is civic
buying this and find and fine dining. Yeah.
And fine dining and getting cash after a bunch of money by dudes who apparently
don't want anything in return. Okay.
Bro, if you don't get the outta here. Okay.
That being sad. But anyways,
let us know what you guys think of the commons below.
What do you guys think about these red pill? Dating coaches?
Are any of them really about what they claim to be.